you
we're going to take the laptop we're
going to put it into a backpack and we
are going to take the vibe and attach a
new battery source to it so that way we
can play VR with no strings attached
okay open a game let's put this thing in
a backpack put that in there too I lost
power lost my word a lot no I still
don't see anything
look the game is running fine it's the
headset why does this work why is it not
working
nobody knows next time on the salmon eco
vlogs so the guys from a horas they saw
our VR and backpack video so they sent
us a computer to see if we can do VR and
backpack using this beauty right here do
this all the way from Beijing good way
to do it like an x-men with that thing
ah next minute which x-men I wrote sure
whoa his laptop super thin stinner than
a razor yet Ethernet HDMI VGA USB that's
the power button
please read the following instructions
do we want to be super classy and choose
the United Kingdom English you have to
get watching some of the old videos
trying to get some ideas for some
t-shirt designs what ow yes so would you
guys like to see on that t-shirt
let me know might be on shirt I guess I
should show you guys how cool this be
our backpack thing is huh
it's running smooth now I'm going to
unplug it
so now the trick is to close the lid see
if it keeps running okay there dude this
might work now let's put it in a
backpack cool never got to tuck in all
these wires here we go hollow point some
space right
Oh
yeah it's working fine sorting great
yeah there's a desktop 980 in it I'm
really surprising I should pull that off
sweet we're just to go to Walker
so LaBrie
Oh
and movin
hold on back up for a second make sure I
have clear I decide the base stations
over heat it again
what's because all the freaking Vince
are being covered up by what are the
straps oh they're the netting facing
we're just in the back oh yeah I'm just
saying the ones on the sides
okay well that's that I guess you turn
the air conditioning up hmm
freedom is super super cool be able to
move around and feel like you're not
gonna run into anything or trip over
your cord it runs just fine if I have
it's like sitting on the on the
ground like if it's plugged it on the
ground it's great if it's not pulling
down on the ground it's still great so
the issue is when it's on my back in a
backpack I gets too hot how hot is this
peeking totter Nico that's not easy
so after multiple experiments and trial
and error and scoured that the thing
that is causing this to change is when
you unplug and replug the power jug in
too hard and it loses sync in the VR
headset goes gray my plug it back in it
comes back so I'm thinking the solution
to something like this is you need an
actual battery like a little power brick
that you can plug into the laptop to get
that extra bit of juice thanks for your
byte for sending us the address our
hooves a ruse laptop is the x7d T if
you're actually looking for a laptop
that has a decent GPU in it like you
won't be able to play games off your TV
and stuff this thing does do the job as
a 980 in it a desktop 980 it's crazy
I look at that it's pretty far away
you